we are days away from the game awards
with leaks and rumors coming in thick
and fast his Roundup of the biggest
things we expect to see at the event
there's a really strong chance we'll be
getting a look at the upcoming sequel to
Star Wars Jedi Fallen order Jedi
Survivor according to Jeff grob of
Gamespot sister site Giant Bomb
marketing for the game will be kicking
off in December and expects the launch
of the title to be March 2023 then
inside a gaming provided specific
details around the game's Presence at
the game awards including a new trailer
release date and pre-order details this
would line up with the recent reveal of
Italian book Jedi Battle Scars that
Bridges part of the five-year gap
between the end of Fallen order and the
beginning of Survivor this year there
has been an absolute ocean of rumors
leaks and teasers out of Kojima
Productions and what they could possibly
be working on next horror game an
anthology series a sequel to Death
stranding Metal Gear Solid 6. okay that
last one I made up but what if
considering the recent cheeses from
Kojima himself as well as the fact the
guy is a certified Bros with producer
and host of The Game Awards Jeff Keeley
it seems almost inevitable the gaming
Autos next title will be at the event on
December 1st Kojima tweeted an image
with three logos and the caption start a
new Journey according to reports from
insiders Kojima Productions is working
on two games a horror title code named
project overdose which has already
leaked footage and death stranding too
the prevailing theory is that these
logos which were also present with
official reveal images that act as Ellie
Fanning and shiori katsuna would be a
part of the project are related to
overdose rather than death stranding 2.
the previously mentioned leaked footage
also revealed that Margaret Corley the
actor behind death stranding's character
mama is also in the game no word on
release date and no concrete info on
whether overdose will be the exclusive
that Kojima is working on for Xbox but
hopefully a lot of these messy details
will be cleared up by the time the game
awards wraps Jedi Survivor and overdose
are just the tip of the iceberg of what
to expect from the game awards the rest
of the rumors include an appearance from
Diablo 4 with pre-orders going live
during the show more from Final Fantasy
16 particularly as its producer nyoki
Yoshida is confirmed to be at the event
updates for Among Us news from publisher
505 potentially a better look at Tekken
8 and a possible tease of the next game
from Joseph Faris and hazelite the game
director and Studio behind last year's
game awards Game of the Year winner it
takes two Joseph is confirmed to also be
attending the event another game we
could learn more about very soon if not
at the game award is Assassin's Creed
Mirage the game currently has a broad
release date of 2023 but according to
Insider gaming the current Target for
the release month is August of next year
rumors before mirage's reveal earlier
this year spoke of an early 2023 release
date but inside a gaming claims that the
game has already been delayed internally
twice if you're looking to get prepped
for the release of this backed Basics
installment in the franchise Assassin's
Creed valhalla's latest DLC shared
history sets up the game by introducing
its protagonist aval to Roshan the
mentor to mirage's protagonist Basim who
is in turn mentor to evil if story
driven RPGs like Assassin's Creed aren't
your bag perhaps upcoming competitive
shooter hyenas from the developers of
Total War creative assembly is today the
game launches an alpha that runs until
Sunday December 4th at 4 pm Eastern
plays sign up for the test at the link
in the description and that is it for
today's Gamespot news what do you hope
to see at this year's game awards are
you going to sign up for that hyenas
Alpha let us know in the comments below
and we'll see you here for more Gamespot
news